president biden trying to project
confidence while some inside the white
house are worried about what lies ahead
reports piling up about concerns over
the economy
political allies are faulting the white
house for mixed messaging
on the recovery there are also concerns
about growing inflation
and axios is reporting some democrats
and economists think the president's
spending plans
could be too big and the gas crisis the
biden administration told americans
would soon go away
is still happening in washington d.c 71
percent of stations are out of gas
and other states are still experiencing
shortages
so while warning signs may be flashing
president biden is telling americans
there's nothing to worry about
we've gone from stagnation to an economy
that is growing
faster than it has in nearly 40 years
we've gone from anemic job creation
to a record of creation for more for a
new administration
none has ever created this many jobs in
this time frame
the progress is undeniable greg then
when you
hear your allies are complaining about
your messaging that usually actually
points to a
fact problem not a messaging one yes
first of all i had no
idea that it was national road work day
yes it is as a matter of fact and you
know it's infrastructure week here on
the
wearing the official color of their
signs and i think that was i think
that's really admirable you you need to
support them
try to i try to participate i was going
to make a different uh comment but
the producer said i should probably shut
up look okay
there are two things that biden says he
says the bi uh he says that the economy
is growing faster in nearly 40 years
and that he also inherited an anemic
economy
but it forces everybody else when they
hear that to do the cleanup that you
don't you can't fact check that you have
to do a
complete fact sex change the two facts
that he's pushing
are only positive if you pretend the
pandemic didn't exist the economy was
anemic because we had the shutdown
and the economy is coming back because
the shutdown is ending it is that simple
to make that your one-two punch is kind
of pathetic
and i do think that the reason why you
don't see him
or anybody in the media too worried
about the gas stuff is because they
don't drive
it's really stupid but i'll make a
generalization about this
most people in the media don't drive
they don't care about this because they
don't have a job that requires gasoline
they don't even know how to pump their
own gas the problem is they are not
aware that
all the people around them that need gas
that rely on fuel the truckers the
amazon delivery people that send
that bring your pilates mat uh the
seamless driver that brings you your
you know your thai food and uh so you
may not drive but
other people are doing the uh the
driving for you
degan a lot of the concerns about the
economy had been theoretical for a long
time like the possibility of inflation
or shortages and those kinds of things
piling up but now
from your perspective is there concrete
evidence of any of that
yes it just remains to be seen how much
people's expectations about inflation
change because once you expect inflation
that's when those high prices
are here to stay for a really long time
i'll argue that this is joe biden's
america
and the real world consequences just
showed up a hell of a lot faster than
any democrats expected
just in time for the midterms that's why
they're worried
whoops the we're all getting to see
where this
baidarian brilliance would take this
country open borders
done happened really quickly the only
problem is
the democrats could manage the optics
gas lines
biden promised to transition away from
the oil industry
half of his infrastructure plan is aimed
at eliminating
fossil fuels he already killed the
keystone xl pipeline on day one
and then jen granholm the energy
secretary says
oh well if you just drove an electric
car you wouldn't be having
a problem with the gasoline shortages
then on top of that you have government
handouts and runaway spending
that extra 300 for unemployment is
nothing compared to the four ginormous
entitlements uh universal pre-k
free child care free community college
and paid family leave that biden has
plans to implement but you don't even
have to work for them so how do you do
it the federal reserve keeps printing
money
it's buying up all the debt and what do
you get crushing
inflation that is a regressive tax on
people who actually choose to work
right so when you go to the store to buy
things it costs a lot more that's like a
tax what you mean
so one this is a cover of the new york
post today
it says that joe biden has proven
proving even more of a master of
disaster
than jimmy carter i'm assuming you
probably think that's a little too
strong
give you a chance to talk about that
well i mean i you know i like tabloids
as much as the next guy
catch my attention as i'm walking past
the newsstand but
uh it's just not real i mean let's just
take a look at public opinion the public
opinion polls
joe biden's well over 50 percent in
almost all the posts i think an ap was
like a 60
approval so that's just a reality touch
i mean you think about his policies
in terms of dealing with covet or in
terms of his infrastructure plan
again the american people like these
policies they like the plan
so i just think you know yeah he has his
critics but
you know it the big one to me in terms
of the polls by the way dana
is that for the first time i think in
like four years mostly american people
now say the country's on the right track
that is such an optimistic positive way
of seeing
what's going on and i think joe biden
deserves some credit for it
by the way i'm a driver especially on
weekends i don't have to drive too much
during the week but on the weekends you
know i get out and about
and uh i got gas in dc this weekend i
think most of the gas stations in
virginia and maryland the
adjacent jurisdictions they have gas so
and i think most people understand this
wasn't the work of any policy
this is the work of hackers hackers from
russia
so uh the fact that it's everything is
being
i think resupplied things are getting
better i think it's a sign again
america can adjust when difficult times
when turbulence hit uh
but you know just overall i wanted to
just respond to what i heard
i just think the economy is going from
zero standstill
because of covet we put it in a sleep
essentially
and now it's coming back to life it's
going from standstill to
hyper speed and there's going to be
turbulence you may not have your
chick-fil-a
sauces you may have a shortage of catch
up here lumber there
used cars over there but it's just like
you know on a take-off
when you hit a little turbulence every
big sign
stock markets you know treasury bonds
all
good stuff jesse that was just basically
like winding you up
and i'll let you go yeah juan's not
panicking but the white house is you
always say the biden white house doesn't
panic well now there's three reports
that saying they're panicking
that means it's ten times worse than
they're actually saying
biden's probably having his dog bite
people he's so angry
um the reason why inflation juan is such
a political killer
is because it affects the left
and the right equally but it affects
the poor and the rich unequally so it
gives rise to populism
something joe biden barely tamed and is
still boiling beneath the surface
so but forget about what it does to a
politician it can set countries back
years like what it did to germany
or brazil and it happens only because
you spend and print too much money
so we've asked for it and joe biden's
300
weekly bonus is now creating a
high unemployment situation you combine
inflation
high unemployment you get stagflation a
wonderful word to say
stagflation sounds so good to say but is
a horrible thing to experience
and the only thing you can do to beat
stagflation or inflation
is raise rates and stop printing money
and when you do that
the economy suffers so what are they
going to do
joe biden's going to have to act because
the longer you wait
the the harder it is to take care of and
joe biden's toolbox
is limited because anything he tries the
left is going to freak out
if he tries to say hey republicans maybe
i'll lower the cost of my plans
they'll freak out if he says hey let's
stop the border
influx so we can maybe raise wages
left is going to freak out if he says
you know energy producers let's try to
increase supply
take some price pressure off left's
going to freak out
so eventually fed's going to have to
jump in they're going to have to raise
rates
it's going to hurt the economy and
biden's going to do just what barack
obama did
blame his predecessor for the bad
recovery
remember that get a mop and by the way
greg i wore this in honor of your
logo i thought so exclamation point it
was either that or circus peanuts
oh do you like those no i hate them i
kind of like those when i was growing up
delicious i'm a redneck though so me too
all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to
fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else